Black Panther gave us a spectacular
big-screen introduction to Wakanda with
a politically charged and emotional
thriller that has important implications
for the Marvel Cinematic Universe
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
and today I'm discussing the thrilling
ending to Black Panther and what it all
means for future Marvel movies in case
you don't know already I'll do regular
videos about superhero movies and I'm
currently also running a black panther
giveaway for a chance to win be sure to
subscribe and leave a comment below
about the movie obviously spoilers ahead
so take care if you haven't seen Black
Panther yet there are a number of themes
woven into black panther that gets some
resolution by the end of the movie but
let's start with a very final scene
before the credits which is when
T'Challa and sure revisit the basketball
caught an apartment block in Oakland
where the movies opening flashback scene
was set
there's an interesting symmetry between
the beginning and the end of the film
which demonstrates T'Challa has made a
concrete decision to lead a positive
change in the world and correct the
wrongs committed by his father to Chaka
and Zuri aka James back in 1992 when
they confronted two chackers brother
about helping Klaus steal vibranium it
was in Oakland where two chaka killed
his brother in Jobu though he did this
to save Zoe his actions sowed the seeds
of anger and resentment in Printz and
Joba son Erik aka kill manga when they
chose to abandon him rather than take
care of him unlike his father T'Challa
is determined to stop operating in
secret and he openly lands his royal
Talon fighter on the basketball court
both in this scene and the subsequent
mid-credits scene to charla proves that
he's ready to reveal the truth about
what Kanda he also wants Wakanda to have
a positive impact on the world by
converting the apartment block which was
the location of the tragedy in the
flashback scene as well as the buildings
either side of it in torque and an
Outreach Center and he appoints Nakia as
head of social outreach while sharee
will spearhead a science exchange of
course it's just a coincidence but given
that Stirling K Brown plays and Jobu
this moment made me think of the TV
drama this is us and how Browns
character Randall buys the rundown
building where his father had lived so
he could improve life for everyone
living there that final Oakland scene
also shows the culmination of T'Challa
zark in the movie by proving that he
could be king and still be a good man
if you're wondering what I mean by this
remember when T'Challa visited his
father on the ancestral plane after
ingesting the heart-shaped herb for the
first time well to checker told his son
you're a good man with a good heart and
it's hard for a good man to be king
T'Challa later learned what his father
meant by this when Zuri revealed how
he'd helped to Chaka hide the truth
about what happened to enjoy boo in his
son Erik finally during their second
meeting on the ancestral plane - Chaka
admitted to his son that he'd chosen
with candor and its people over his
nephew and that lie about the events in
Auckland that truth was - Chaka chose to
bury for many years actually as T'Challa
puts it ended up creating a monster in
the form of kill mango these moments of
Revelation in black panther reminded me
of thor ragnarok
spoiler alert if you've not seen that
movie yet because we discovered in that
film that Odin had hidden his daughter
Heller in her role and violently
conquering the nine realms each of these
stories involves concealing both the
existence of relatives to Charlie's
cousin and Thor sister and the violence
sometimes used to maintain seemingly
benevolent rule and of course in both
stories it's the sons who were left
dealing with a damage caused by their
father's actions
T'Challa is appalled by what - Chuck a
did and takes a nakiya's advice not to
let his father's mistakes define him as
she said you get to decide what kind of
King you're going to be and that's
exactly what - Charla does when he
refuses to stay with his father in the
ancestral plane the second time they
meet them instead of joining his
ancestors - Charla chooses to return to
a candor and prove he can be a good man
and a good king by affecting real change
in the world sharing his nation's
resources and technology for the
betterment of others by the end of the
film - Charlie's eyes have been opened
by both Makia who told him she had seen
too many a need to turn a blind eye any
longer and also by the events that led
Erik on the past become kill monger Hill
mongers death is another crucial moment
in black panther in keeping with his
beliefs he preferred to die than be
imprisoned and his death in front of the
wakandan sunset was an emotional link
back to the words he shared with his
father about what cannon sunsets being
most beautiful in the world in addition
to the symmetry between the film's
opening and closing scenes in Oakland
there's also a certain symmetry around
the fates of kill monger and his father
and Jobu each of whom died in
complicated circumstances at the hands
of a relative to Chaka had wanted his
brother to Facebook and as counsel for
his crimes but ended up killing him to
save Zuri while jacala was defending
himself from Kill Mangrum were candor
from his rule but ultimately offered his
cousin the healing power of wakandan
technology as the movie's main
antagonist kill mangas worldview was
very much in opposition to Black
Panthers outlook but then the two men
had very different upbringings T'Challa
was raised in Wakanda which due to the
vibranium meteorite was able to isolate
itself in the world was therefore never
subject the colonialism experienced by
their African neighbors on the other
hand in many ways kill manga represents
the African experience as a result of
colonialism slavery and racism Erik was
brought up in Auckland which is both the
birthplace of the film's director Ryan
Coogler and the city were in 1966 the
real-life Black Panther Party began with
a focus on combating police brutality
against the black community by the way
1966 was also the year Black Panther
first appeared in Marvel Comics in
khulus film as we learn from Zuri kill
mongers father and Joe who experience
discrimination in Oakland and that led
him to act against wakandan policy by
smuggling out vibranium in an effort to
fight back when kil manga takes over as
rule of Wakanda he declares that the Sun
will never set on the wakandan Empire
echoing the phrase used to describe the
former Spanish and British empires which
was so large it was said to be always
daytime some worm kill manga further
overturns Buckhannon traditions when he
orders the burning of the heart-shaped
herb and director Ryan Coogler reflects
kill mongers revolution and the fact
he's turning how a candidate's
completely on its head by having the
camera revolver 180 degrees for an
upside down position as a new King
enters a throne room Michael B Jordan
has said of kil manga that he's always
ten steps ahead he's very patient now
it's a very dangerous attribute to have
as a villain because he's going to sit
and wait and he's going to plan and
calculate every move kil manga gained
both tactical and military skills on
combo
missions in countries such as
Afghanistan and Iraq and he appears to
kill his girlfriend and then also claw
who he's been collaborating with
seemingly without hesitation when he
deems it necessary to getting into
Wakanda kill monger is incredibly
effective and ruthless in carrying out
his plan to take over the nation yet
despite his extremes you can empathize
with his grievances in short he's an
incredible antagonist and although
ultimately kill manga fails to complete
his plans the fact that T'Challa is
deeply affected by the experiences of
enjoy Buu and kill manga and the actions
of takaka means that other kids from
Auckland can now believe in work and
ruin it's incredible technological
advances without thinking is just a
fairy tale it really is good to see
Marvel developing their villains better
in recent movies and Michael B Jordan is
such a fantastic actor who brought so
much to this film that it's a real shame
to think he won't be returning but kill
manga did have a great arc the other
great secondary villain in the movie was
ulysses klaw played in a brilliantly
unhinged and hereís why by Andy Serkis
and again it's a pity his character is
dead of course these are comic-book
movies so technically any character can
still come back from the dead in fact
there is one Marvel villain I do think
could make a stunning return in the MCU
for a very good reason and that's a
certain Green Goddess and you can check
out my theory on why I think we'll see
her again right here an important
recommendation that T'Challa followed
from his father was to surround himself
with good people and it was his little
sister Shuri who played a huge role in
helping him take back the throne she and
Nakia are extremely loyal to jacala
though both of them have a rebellious
streak and they encourage the young king
to push beyond the status quo Shuri
herself is constantly pushing herself to
another level actively developing and
improving her tech indeed as she told
her brother just because it works
doesn't mean it can't be improved in
fact that's something I think T'Challa
takes onboard in opening up Wakanda and
it was great to see sure he's so excited
in the final scene when her brother
announced she was going to lead the work
and and Technology exchange with the
rest of the world I can't wait to see
what text she gets to develop an
Avengers infinity war and I'd love to
see
meet Tony Stark at some point as I think
their banter and talk about amazing
inventions could be fantastic there's
also the possibility she could Donna
black panther suit of her own in the
future and as a hint at that by the
tooths neck piece she whirs and some
scenes in the film by the way I think
it's interesting that the newer Canon
Center will be established in Oakland
because the next Marvel movie after
Avengers infinity war is ant-man and the
wasp which is set in San Francisco in
geographically Oakland is just across
the bay in fact the Oakland Bay Bridge
made an appearance in the first ant-man
and the wasp trailer and I wonder
whether there's a chance we could see
black panther or some more canned and
characters crossover into that movie
later this year another thing - Charla
achieves by the end of the film was a
sort of repairing of relations with the
Javari tribe whose leader mbaku does not
take kindly at first to his request that
they join him against kill manga as
previous Kings have not bothered to
visit them in centuries
T'Challa spurred him back whose life
during their ritual combat for the
throne but mbaku already repaid that
debt when he helped save T'Challa after
kill monger flung him off the side of a
mountain still in the end mbaku and his
people do rally to to Charla's cause of
saving work and ER from kill manga
because they realize as Black Panther
explained that this affects everyone and
in doing this mbaku and his tribe have a
huge impact on the final battle and
talking of the final battle the door
Malaysia also play a key role with Quyen
literally bringing a rhino to a
standstill by fearlessly confronting her
lover cabbie as soon as she realizes
that kill monger is not the rightful
king she is an incredible fighter as our
Hedorah mulashi sisters and i cannot
wait to see more of them on screen now i
spoke about how important the final
scene is and showing how to Chara is
transforming and opening up work and in
society to the wider world and this
could have a big effect on the rest of
the MCU which we see the beginnings of
when T'Challa addresses the United
Nations in the first end credits scene
and I've actually got a separate video
with a full breakdown of that scene plus
the final stinger scene with Bucky and
what it all means for Avengers infinity
war and you can watch that by tapping
right up here or clicking the link in
the video description below so were you
impress my
Black Panthers first solo movie and are
you hyped to see more of or candan a
sequel and an Avengers infinity war and
which were your favorite characters in
the movie I'd love to hear your thoughts
in the comments below and don't forget
to also subscribe to enter my Black
Panther giveaway the winner of my
Deadpool 2 giveaway is on screen right
now so if that's you make sure you
private message me with your details I
really appreciate all your support so if
you enjoyed this do hit the like button
and share the video and why not join the
notification squad by clicking the bell
for all my new black panther and other
videos coming very shortly also tap any
of the links here to check out more
videos you might like thanks for
watching and see you next time you pick
a movie lovers